what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder and
with the
end of avengers infinity war and the
infinity saga
came marvel's phase four after
spider-man far from home came out
everybody was looking forward to
what is coming with phase four what new
movies what new shows
what new heroes and what new teams of
heroes
disney and fox completed their deal
before the announcement of marvel's
phase 4 allowing marvel and disney to
use the x-men in the fantastic four
along with other characters like
deadpool
in the marvel cinematic universe and
fans were hoping that we would get some
type of an announcement
and we have kevin feige mentioned the
mutants and the fantastic four and
recently at disney's investor day
mentioned the fantastic fours in
development
but right now we have a very grounded
mcu the falcon and the winter soldier is
addressing things that have happened
during and after the blip
and currently as it stands right now we
don't have a
current avengers team however that looks
like it may be changing
in the near future and it sounds like we
won't just be getting one new avengers
team or even
two new ones but could be getting three
new avengers teams and possibly even
four depending on how long the other
avengers teams last
and don't worry i'll be breaking down
each new avengers team that could be
coming to the mcu
starting off with the dark avengers it's
been a while since we've heard about the
dark avengers but a new report actually
states that a dark avengers script
has been commissioned by marvel studios
and i'll break down everything you need
to know but don't forget about tonight's
the falcon and the winter soldier watch
party we're going to be starting it at
11
50 p.m pacific time can't wait to see
you all there
so as i just mentioned one of the first
new avengers groups that could be coming
to the mcu
is the dark avengers and this is
actually very very suiting for the
current state
and time that the mcu is currently in
and the original story of the dark
avengers in the comics could very easily
be adapted to what is happening
in the mcu right now not a page by page
copy of course because that's not what
marvel does but let me explain the
premise of the dark avengers and how
easy it would be to
adapt their storyline into the mcu the
dark avengers are relatively new in
marvel comics they first appeared in
2009 they had 16 issues and ran
throughout the dark rain and siege
storylines
and here's a very quick briefing of what
you need to know about them
this is set in pretty dark times it's
set during the aftermath of the skrull
secret invasion
where some heroes ended up being scroll
in disguise
this leads to the government actually
not really trusting the avengers so the
government reformed shield
now known as hammer and appoints norman
osborne
the head of it when this happened he was
actually leading the thunderbolts team
so he takes this opportunity of his new
state of power to start his own team of
heroes this new team consisted of
century novar
ares matt gargan a spider-man a
moonstone captain marvel
a bullseye hawkeye a dak and wolverine
and norman osborne himself is the iron
patriot
now the thing about the dark avengers is
they are essentially a
government-sanctioned team
again the government didn't trust the
old avengers team so they made a new one
this is currently kind of happening in
the mcu right now
all of the old avengers that win against
the sokovia accords were pardoned they
are criminals no more but you can see
how after civil war and the sokovia
accords the government may not trust the
avengers
even during avengers infinity war
thunderbolt ross was still trying to
arrest part of the team
but of course they saved the world an
avengers end game so their crimes are
essentially forgotten but the government
does not trust them necessarily
and this is actually demonstrated with
the government appointing their own
new captain america in the falcon and
the winter soldier right now we're led
to believe that
falcon gave up the shield and the title
of captain america but
it seems like there's a lot that we
don't know and sam himself says
bucky has to accept the fact that it's
something that him and steve himself
may not understand so perhaps there's
more that meets the eye here
either way it's very clear that these
are dark times right now
in the mcu and it's clear that the
government wants to be in control of the
so-called superheroes
thunderbolt ross wanted this with the
sokovia accords that's what it was
really about
the government controlling the team of
superheroes and now they elected their
own captain america
it seems like it's only a matter of time
until they actually elect their own
avengers team and this is where the dark
avengers would come into play
now we don't have norman osborn in the
mcu yet but who knows what spider-man no
way home has in store for us
it's very possible that they could
introduce him or they could introduce
him in some other way or they actually
kind of don't even need him just because
he's in the comic story line doesn't
mean that he has to be in the mcu
storyline
disney and marvel have confirmed that
they are going to be releasing a marvel
disney plus show titled armor wars this
is going to star roadie who is currently
the iron patriot
and apparently is going to be about what
happens when stark tech falls into the
wrong hands specifically
iron man armors this could introduce
norman osborne or a character similar to
him or rhodey could even be the one
elected to lead the new avengers after
all he is well respected and he is in
the air force currently so he does work
for the government
he'd be a pretty great choice but he'd
most likely run into some problems
considering the fact that they'd
probably want him to do things that he
wouldn't be comfortable with
then of course we have the disney plus
show coming secret invasion
which is about the scroll and the secret
invasion of course this storyline also
sets up the premise for the dark
avengers
and as i mentioned in the beginning a
while ago it was reported that a script
had been commissioned for a dark
avengers either movie or
show and now we have some more rumors
that marvel studios is working on
derivatives of the avengers meaning dark
avengers young avengers
and the west coast avengers which we're
about to talk about right now
the young avengers are pretty obvious
because they've already started to set
them up within the mcu
in one division we were introduced to
the twins billy and tommy
and real quick spoiler alert if you have
not seen the finale of one division we
were introduced to the twins and even
though by the end of one division they
were no more
in the post-credits scene the second
post-credits scene wanda did
hear them calling out to her implying
that they will come
back then we have harley keener from
iron man 3 who was there at tony stark's
funeral at the end of avengers end game
of course kate bishop is going to be
introduced in the hawkeye series played
by haley steinfeld kamala khan is coming
with the introduction of the miss
marvel series on disney plus and
seemingly in the falcon and the winter
soldier in the last episode they just
recently introduced eli bradley the son
of isaiah bradley
and eli is one of the founding members
of the young avengers and goes by the
hero name
of patriot so the groundwork for the
young avengers has already been laid and
it's only a matter of time until they
actually appear as a group
then we have the west coast avengers and
it seems like we may have gotten the
start of this team
in one division with the introduction of
white vision
the west coast avengers was an avengers
group started by hawkeye at the
suggestion of
vision and in the comics the west coast
avengers vision
is white vision and this is a separate
group from the original avengers that's
meant to expand
the avengers influence and the fact that
one division introduced us to this new
version of vision who is a white version
and just
disappeared during the finale to who
knows where
could be the start of the west coast
avengers because we know that he's going
to come back marvel just doesn't
introduce people and send them away to
never see them again there's a specific
purpose here and hopefully he does come
back and play a pretty big role in a new
avengers team
and of course i have to mention the
actual new avengers team
all these avengers teams are kind of
side avengers teams but they are
exciting nonetheless but of course when
the time comes for the world to need
our actual avengers team we're going to
be introduced to
the new avengers and of course this team
is going to consist of characters that
we've already seen
and some new characters to come and we
know that it's going to be super
super exciting and of course if i hear
any news about that i'll be sure to do a
video updating you so be sure to
subscribe and hit the notification bell
so you don't miss out on any of the
latest videos
in the meantime let me know what you
think about these other avengers teams
and let me know which avengers team you
would be most excited about
in the comments down below don't forget
to like the video and for live updates
you can follow me on instagram and
twitter
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof